يلا في عمليه ولاده قد تكون هذه مثيره
للجدل بريطانيا شهدت ولاده اول طفل من
الحمض النووي له ثلاثه اشخاص في اجراء
يهدف لمنع انتقال الامراض الوراثيه للطفل
تعريفه بس العلماء في مركز زانيوكاسل
للخصوبه استخدموا تقنيه تعرف باسم علاج
التبرع
بالميتوكوندريا المسؤوله عن انتاج الطاقه
في خلايا الجسم وذلك بهدف منع الام النقل
الجينات المريضه لطفلها يتضمن الاجراء
الجديد تلقيحا اصطناعيا باستخدام الحمض
النووي مو لشخص ولا اثنين لثلاثه اشهر
وعاده شخصين بس هاي فعلا يعني جهاز علمي
الجنين في هذه الاجراء مشاهدينا يتلقى
الحمض النووي الذي يحدد الخصائص الرئيسيه
مثل الشخصيه ولون العين من والده ووالدته
الحقيقيين في حين يتم اعطاؤه كميه ضئيله
نحو
0.1% فقط من الحم
من امراه اخرى
الى الان ما ندري شنو الاعراض الجانبيه
والانسحابيه فقط هو اكتشاف علمي خلينا
نشوفه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات